this is a production of Cornell
University
okay so I'm gonna be talking about
malting barley today which is barley
that's used to make beer and whiskey
which makes for some fun okay so as many
of you know there's a lot of craft
brewing that goes on in New York so much
so that were the fifth largest producer
of beer in the nation some of that
growth has been spurred by the farm
brewery bill which is passed by the
state government in 2012
this gives economic incentives to local
Brewers to use local ingredients
ingredients being malt and hops so right
now these farm brewers have to use 20%
of their ingredients being from New York
however by 2019 that's gonna bump up to
60% so as you can see we're not growing
a whole lot of barley in New York right
now
it's creeping up but we have some
progress to make so we can meet that 90%
minimum by 2024 so the small grains
group has been trialing moulting Bart
barley and starring some research since
about 2013 but for many reasons which
I'll go into we decide to actually start
some breeding research which we're
calling the born bred and brewed a New
York project which I will hereafter
referred to as the DPP okay so our main
goals here are to actually breed barley
that's adapted to the unique conditions
of New York understand how genotype
environment and Gbowee interactions
affect multi across the state
established best management practices
for New York growers since this is a
very new crop in New York we still don't
really know what best way to grow barley
is and then variety trying and
recommendation my work focuses on these
first two points which I'll be covering
today okay so before I continue I wanted
to give a brief overview of the malting
and brewing process for those who aren't
familiar so with any crop it starts with
seed I'm working in spring barley so we
plant this in middle mid to end of April
and harvest in early August so this is a
picture of my nursery of this summer at
the Helfer field so you need clean plump
disease-free grain to malt malting is
three steps you steep the grain so it
imbibes water
can germinate germination the second
process and then you dry it and kill a
heat to develop enzymes color and flavor
so this is germinating barley right here
these little reutlitz are called chit
and then this is a almost finished malt
product you can see the dried reutlitz
right here this has been dried so once
you have the malt you go on to the
brewing process which starts with
grinding them all steeping it in water
to remove the sugars that gives you a
kind of a malt soup which is called
worked this is work here you add hops to
the work you boil it to extract hot
compounds and sterilize it cool it add
yeast fermentation commences and then
after fermentation you sometimes filter
it let it rest for a little bit and then
you bottle it so you can enjoy it
okay so I mentioned that there are some
challenges for growing barley in New
York mostly because of the weather we
have so this map this graphic is from
the USDA harvested barley acreage in
2016 as you can see New York is
producing so much barley that they
didn't even serve a New York most of it
is being grown in the Upper Great Plains
in the Mountain West where they have
warm days cool nights and low humidity
low humidity means low disease and it
also means that it will not pre harvest
sprout so that's what happens when the
grain has low dormancy it gets wet
before harvest and the grain starts the
germination process this is bad because
it means that barley is not malts very
well because malting is germination um
the other big problem we have in humid
areas is Fusarium head blight which is a
fungal pathogen that infects the
developing spike and produces a nasty
mycotoxin called the ox so even up here
in middle nowhere montana malting barley
is a tricky crop to grow so the main the
the traits that we're really interested
in and that are going to be key to
actually getting malting barley to work
in New York are disease resistance free
harvest spreading resistance and good
enough from all quality the craft
maltsters and brewers actually want to
use this stuff so most of our germ plasm
is actually from this area because this
is where the
reading programs are and also Western
Canada they produce a very large amount
of our barley up there but also European
varieties from France and Germany
Germany girls a lot of barley if they
can grow malting barley ok so the method
that we're using to actually go about
achieving this goal is multi parental
genomic selection in a reduced method
Association mapping panel design so I'll
talk about the next couple slides kind
of mouthful so there have been a lot of
genomic prediction studies within by
parental families and you can get pretty
good prediction accuracy within by
parental families for most part however
there are not that many and connected by
parental families these are two examples
from algorithm Elkin Gers group in
Germany these are both maize so
basically from these publications there
is some promise that combining acid
families can give you better prediction
accuracies than just single by parental
families this is also useful breeding
model for us because there's one variety
called AEC synergy that we really like
it's from Western Canada but its biggest
problem is that it sprouts like crazy
because it doesn't rain in Canada up
there and they don't need smart
resistance so we really just want to
modify want to improve one trait
maybe with two traits and this crossing
the single parent to six other seven
other parents excuse me gives us a
reasonable breeding strategy as well as
academically interesting job prediction
so the last year and a half to two years
I've been developing this training
population I have about fourteen hundred
two rows spring barley lines from seven
full subfamilies like I said are
connected by a single common female
parent I have two locations this year
and since I didn't have that much seed I
had to grow it and head rows and augment
the design
head rows are okay here because I'm not
interested in yield right now or
interested in quality traits and disease
which I could you know type and head
rows just fine I did a lot of phenotype
in the summer I'm actually still doing
some lab and we harvested a subset of
this to send for his scent in New
Zealand or winter nursery seed increase
we can grow some of these and replicate
to heal Charles next year don't know if
all get to go there but maybe next year
okay um I actually don't have a jeep to
pick today yet that's taken a little
longer than I expected actually just got
the last two files back this morning so
if I were presenting in two weeks I
would have had some interesting genomic
things talked about but you're stuck
with phenotypic information which is so
kind of interesting too so because this
is not meant to design sorry the entries
are random so I can calculate bupps and
then nested within check the
heritability ZAR kind of interesting
here so all that means I did all of the
families at once this is all thirteen
hundred and forty two lines and these
are heritability thing each of my seven
families so you see there's quite a
range across each of the traits height
heading date leaf rust spot watch
harvest sprouting most notably and then
the genetic variance over here there's
quite a range so super height and that's
and their traits - one of the more
interesting things you might know is
that this SN family here tends to have
lower heritability x' and lower genetic
variance compared to the other families
this is actually a back cross this
parents called new Dale and it's one of
the parents synergy
we didn't realize in this until after
the fact but I was a happy accident
should make for some interesting
experimental things hi this will not be
being advanced in the breeding lines
though okay oh and then I fit these with
air one air one row column for their
instructors in a stroller and the
spatial effects did improve the models
so I kept them in even though there
wasn't noticeable spatial variation okay
so again I haven't actually
any prediction yet but I have a lot of
interesting look at I'll just start with
our bluff and probably base models since
I'm expecting for some of these trades
there to be some major key TL
segregating major effect QTL so the most
obvious I can start leper well within
family predictions across family
predictions whole set two whole set we
also have a population from the
University of Minnesota to row spring
barley is genotypes and phenotypes so
that's unrelated then I can do various
combinations of all these so I have a
lot of work ahead of me again I was
hoping to present on some of this today
but come back next year and there'll be
some good stuff I also have kind of a
mini experiment within the genomic
selection experiment going and a really
selection versus random interesting
looking at spatial correction versus
just raw data because of the population
structure design I should be able to run
G Oster this will see if I have any
major qto like in fit as fixed effects
and because of the size here I can
empirically look at optimal size for the
training set okay I had a speed through
this so I'm actually gonna be doing
selection - so I'll be removing two
families crossing between all the others
phenotypic and genomic selection
advancing simultaneously there's not a
lot out there and actually using
selection indices for genomic selection
there's an Elliott Hoefler paper from
back in the day they just looked at it
but from a prediction standpoint they
didn't actually do any selections with
the selection index but because we're
actually trying to do some breeding here
and I blog you know types I would like
to look at that quickly I want to talk
about another project - it's related to
malting so multi is a super important
phenotype it's made up of eight to ten
quantitative traits so it's loads of fun
but it's really expensive takes a lot of
grain usually in later generations like
any quality trait there are micro Multi
machines but they're also expensive so I
decided to make my own this is a kind of
crappy cartoon showing a hydroponic Evan
so water moves up into this top tray
barley grain is suspended in mesh bags I
have 10 grams so I'm calling it nano
melting so I can fit a whole lot in this
3x3 table the steeping takes place in
here the germination takes place in here
and this is all in a growth chamber to
keep relative humidity and temperature
constant I'm so done a couple test runs
this is my so these are my mesh bags
here and this grain you can see the size
here I'm killing these in a food
dehydrator the phenotypes of interest
looking at a green protein mulberry
glucan and extract and we have some nice
regional trial
grain samples from the past three years
winter and spring barley multiple
locations so do a little g'bye emote
study which will be fun okay quick
acknowledgments thank my committee mark
Gary and Jessica um everybody in the
soils lab particularly James for lab and
greenhouse help David ventured Amy Fox
and Jesse Chavez for field help David
especially for doing all the disease
inoculation Jamie Cummings in the
Bergstrom lab for making a inoculum
particularly the by Polaris which is a
big amount of work so very grateful to
her in the friction lab for that
Elizabeth says for ecology questions
Julie Hanson for letting me use the
viands lab NIR machine Nick Casimir for
letting me use his Evan flow table which
I will get back to at some point is
alone and then air McLeod from heartwood
College who runs the Kraft food and
beverage center and as a multi science
wizard and has helped us out a lot yeah
I think NY I drink NY and I'll be happy
to take any questions
[Applause]
here yeah so we've tested some UK spring
wines I I think they might actually grow
a little bit more winter grain because
their winters are not nearly as harsh as
they are here but the UK material
somewhat surprising is not done well
here we have by far of the best luck in
European germplasm with French and
German varieties and there are many
French and German private companies that
are actively involved in spring barley
breeding and finish - but that's a
pretty different environment from New
York so we're mostly focusing like kws
psycho bruh Syngenta bryan material
yeah
so there are hybrid there is hybrid
barley in Europe but is primarily for
feed I don't know the name is looked at
hybrid barley for moulting quality I
think that you'd probably run in the
same problem the hybrid rice has that it
might yield like crazy but people don't
like the quality and malting barley is
the breeding programs are fully dictated
by what the Brewers want and because of
that the North American hero barley germ
plasm base is extremely narrow because
selection for the malting quality
parameters for industrial brewing is so
precise there's no one over there may be
something at rest to look into but I'm
not aware of any hybrid malting
varieties that are being researched yeah
so I should be able to compare it to
micro malts we so the benefit of using
those regional trials is that we send
one rep of one location to the USDA
small grains quality lab in Madison
Wisconsin so I have a comparison there I
can also send some samples to Erin
McLeod he has a micro Malter so and I
need to do that because I'm not going to
be confident that I'm doing it right
unless I absolutely compare it to
Michael yes yes yeah so yeah yeah well
so that one bad cross that I talked
about that's also they're both adapted
to what they call the Canadian quality
so Canadian quality means that it yields
well and it sprouts when you spit on it
because the big Canadian maltsters want
to be fast and efficient there's also
disease I guess I was a little too
simplistic and saying there's one trait
we want to improve upon we could improve
some disease resistance as well I think
so it appears that the pre-harvest
sprouting from the past QTL mapping
papers and barley is all ago genic it's
not quite quantitative and based on the
heritability x' i'm seeing and my
distribution i think that it's probably
all ago genic so i'm hoping to have some
success and getting good prediction
accuracies and actually selecting for
free harvest sprouting because we want
it as low as possible yes that's a good
question
so there is a skill level difference you
have guys that have been brewing in
their basement for the last five years
and decided to start selling it and you
have people that are professionally
trained and they doing this for 30 years
so there's there's a skill level
difference I would say that raw
materials are probably pretty similar at
this point they all have access to the
same malt they could be buying New York
malts if they wanted to or they could be
buying it from a large scale maltster in
Oregon or Washington or Minnesota water
can actually make a big difference in
the taste of the beer and the quality of
the beer so if there are water
differences across the state that could
potentially be part of it but a lot of
it's actually skill
and the way you market it and there are
a lot of different beer styles that I
could give a whole nother 30 minute
seminar on so maybe I could do that for
a grass group sometime people want to
know about beer I could one last
question if not let's thank Dan
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu